I know some of you are watching
anxiously waiting for news desperate to
hear that your mother or father or
husband or wife still alive in their
long term care home you're not allowed
to visit even phone calls are of limited
use especially if your loved one is
nonverbal or has dementia I get it my
parents spent their final days in a care
home and as harsh as it sounds I'm
relieved they passed away before this
pandemic hit because it is inside these
long-term care homes that this
coronavirus is taking hold and taking
lives half the deaths from kovat 19 in
canada are in care homes and in the most
grim cases people are left to die alone
in their beds and it's not like there
were no warnings the families dread the
distance when only want is to be inside
holding a hand all they can do is keep
vigil outside fourth floor fourth when
you're across anything to catch sight of
those dear to them now isolated inside
any precious sign they're okay
like a wildfire the coronavirus has
blazed through Canada's long-term care
homes exposing cracks and faults in the
system from coast to coast to coast
there are now outbreaks in more than 600
facilities accounting for nearly half
the deaths from kovat 19 in Canada
including the very first we
unfortunately have had to death here in
British Columbia it happened here at the
Linn Valley care center in North
Vancouver and it was here too that a
health care worker a woman in her 50s
became Canada's first reported case of
community transmission a troubling sign
the virus had taken hold among our most
vulnerable
public health officials rushed to trace
her contacts and tried to contain the
spread but those who knew best feared
the worst
if you have people in your gathering who
are who are elderly or more I just know
how stressful it is for our healthcare
system for my colleagues and for
families and then the pattern began to
repeat elsewhere at a small nursing home
in Bobcaygeon Ontario nearly half the
residents died in their beds and at
least 28 staff have tested positive it's
a fantastic community and to see this
happening is heartbreaking it actually
is heartbreaking soon there were
multiple outbreaks and care homes across
the country most with a common story a
sudden onslaught of cases sometimes
dozens of dead testing and detection
falling woefully behind the wave
caregivers sick and off work those
remaining struggling to keep up in homes
that were often chronically understaffed
before this pandemic residents sharing
rooms and bathrooms staff lacking
personal protective equipment ideal
conditions for a virus to run rampant
those on the frontlines are mostly women
new immigrants and visible minorities
doing difficult deeply personal work for
low pay bathing feeding
changing adult diapers it can be
exhausting physically and emotionally
and they often work part-time in
multiple facilities to make ends meet it
remains at a critical low we really need
skilled workers in some care homes
there's been a collapse in frontline
staffing some sick some staying away
because the risk is too high in my
workplace we all drop like flies you
have no idea how fast it infects
everybody it's extremely like hard for
us because you grow attached to them you
don't want to refuse but obviously a lot
of people are gonna feel unsafe now
hundreds of homes are locked down
leaving families worried sick
agonizing at the unthinkable loved ones
left alone in their final hours here I
finally get in my father's on his last
breath literally dead lying in his bed
so I went for three weeks thinking my
father was fine he's not he's dead
and there's the harrowing accounts of
what happened inside Montreal's
residents heron the conditions beyond
words those who were still alive were
dehydrated and malnourished and hadn't
been bathed or changed in days most
staff had left a doctor arrived on the
scene so desperate she called her own
husband and teenage children to come and
help thirty-one residents died in three
weeks the government seized control of
the facility and the premier asked for
help from the military
for a nation it's a defining shameful
moment exposing how we treat our elders
no zany new leg in society our elders he
says struggle to leave us a rich and
just society a beautiful society he says
we have a duty to protect them the fact
is our long-term care system is built on
a crumbling foundation this pandemic has
laid bare long-standing issues that
until now we've chosen to largely ignore
doctors Samir Sinha is an advocate for
the needs of older adults he's director
of geriatrics at Mount Sinai and the
University Health Network hospitals in
Toronto and architect of Ontario's
seniors strategy
dr. Sinha first do you think we have a
full and accurate picture of the scale
of outbreaks in care homes and
retirement homes across the country or
have case has been underreported I don't
think we have the accurate picture that
we actually need right now about how
things are progressing across the
country and that's for a bunch of
reasons right now that some of the
ministries for example have data streams
and public health units have data
streams looking at certain types of
homes like nursing homes but not
necessarily retirement homes so the
official numbers that you see coming out
in Ontario really only include nursing
homes but don't actually include
retirement homes that are equally just
as vulnerable and actually are more
numerous in the retirement homes we have
so right now the numbers you're seeing
that really are over a thousand homes
across the country that are affected
don't really give you a cure counts and
the same issues happening in the United
States and the problem with this is that
if we don't have the accurate data then
you can't fight a fire blindfolded you
know what is the biggest failing do you
think of our care home system that has
allowed this virus to take hold with
such ferocity I think the biggest issue
that's really come through or it at the
moment that's really been the about the
way we staff our homes so for example
many homes across the country they don't
usually offer nurses and personal
support workers who work in them the
same wage rates that they would get
working in a hospital so it's no
surprise that the majority of homes
across the country tell us that they
actually have trouble recruiting people
to work in
environments and then they have trouble
actually retaining them because often
when a job opens up at a hospital that
often pays a better wage rate with
benefits like pensions or sick benefits
or sick days for example that people
will jump ship and go there so we have a
real unstable staffing situation you
know the shortage of staff the low pay
the fact staff work in more than one
care home none of that is new all of it
contributed to the spread why weren't
those faults in the system addressed
long ago you know pointing back to the
SARS Commission of 2004 that really
focused on the issue that that staff
working between multiple homes or in
multiple settings was one of the reasons
why stars as a corona virus was
spreading between institutions and
facilities and so it's something that
was recommended way back then that we
actually eliminate that practice and so
former health ministers at the time we
said wait a minute
we made this recommendation back in 2004
why did we never act on it that's a
great question because now we're
actually seeing that while it wasn't
such an issue in the last number of
years because we didn't actually address
that comprehensively people have now
been paying for it with their lives you
know I know from firsthand experience
with my own parents that care home
workers are like angels they work so
hard they do incredibly difficult work
they do it with love and patience why
don't we as a society value them more
pay them more and do you think we will
after this I think we have to I think
this is a massive wake-up call that as
we age as a society we're going to need
more homes like these in the future we
should actually treat these workers I'm
not saying better than but I'm saying at
least equal to the way we actually
respect and treat our workers and
hospitals because these workers are
dealing with some of the sickest and
most rayless people in our country and
frankly that when we don't treat them
well we all pay the consequences of
society and these individuals with their
lives as well you know we've heard from
people who say I want to get my mom or
my dad out of there I'm so worried about
them I can't see them what's your advice
for people should they would you remove
your parent from a care home right now
if I was in BC Alberta I'd say I think
they're getting things under control and
I think we need to make sure we can
support our homes to support our loved
ones well but I'm nervous about people
who have loved ones in care in Ontario
Quebec right now and for those families
who are thinking well we could be we
could possibly bring our loved ones home
on the Ontario government back on March
24 that actually changed the regulations
to support families to do this if this
is the right decision for them you've
spent your career in the field of
geriatrics looking at aging and how to
help the most vulnerable people in our
society when you look at what's
happening in a care homes in so many
places in this country what's your gut
feeling to watch this unfolding it
honestly it's it's it's left me in tears
at times because you know I've dedicated
my life to supporting older Canadians
and enabling them and when I think about
you know 400,000 vulnerable Canadians
across these homes and the fact that we
as a country in many ways have left so
many families and so many individuals
down it tells me that we should have
been doing better and that we can do
better and we have to do better